long time day I'm Jesse Weber tough
questions for investigators Friday as
attorneys in the Alec Murdock murder
trial tried to persuade a jury that they
know the truth of what happened on that
June 9th in 2021. Murdoch is accused of
killing his wife Maggie and his son Paul
possibly to try to direct attention away
from his financial misdeeds the mother
and son were found shot to death in a
huge Farm property that the Murdoch's
own in South Carolina during Friday's
testimony the prosecution and the
defense grilled a South Carolina law
enforcement division detective focusing
a lot on the blood that was found on
around the bodies as well as whether
Alec Murdock had any blood on him now
the detective testified that as far as
she could see on the night of the night
of Murdoch was clean from head to toe
the prosecution seemed to be implying
that this meant Murdoch did not actually
try to roll over Maggie and Paul or
check for sign life signs but the
defense however used that apparent lack
of blood on Murdoch's body and clothes
to say he's not the shooter during
testimony on Friday the Court the court
saw and heard the first interview that
Alec Murdock had with police inside of a
police cruiser at the scene now we have
some of that hour and a half long
interview for you now
when I came back here I mean I pulled up
and I could see him and you know I knew
something was bad I ran out I knew it
was really bad
my boy over there I could see it was
laughs
foreign
I could see his brains
[Music]
and I ran over to Maggie and
actually I think I tried to turn Paul
over first
um
uh
you know I tried to turn him over and uh
I don't know I figured it out
um
his cell phone popped out of his pocket
that's
started to try to do something with it
thinking maybe but then I put it back
down really quickly
um then I went to my wife and I
I mean I could see hmm
all right I'm joined by my co-host legal
experts Brian buckmeyer Terry Austin
Brian will start with you a lot to sort
through today as all this evidence and
the testimony what did you pick up on
yeah Jesse so we're all watching the
same thing there in the video trying to
gauge whether or not Alec Murdock is
faking it or truly in distress but as I
listen to the detectives testimony there
was one point in the detective testimony
that stood out to me check this out
you had a meeting and you you looked at
uh some photos
I believe crime scene photos and autopsy
photos that sled right I did and you
made a mental note and you put it in
your record that that you notice a few
strands of what appeared to be brown
hair unable to determine the length from
the photo in Maggie's hands and fingers
right that is correct and you thought
that that possibly was an indication of
a struggle that Maggie can grab someone
had their hair in her hands right I
didn't say that in my report no
well so why did you note it in your
report
because it was an observation
yeah so I know there are a lot of people
saying that's potentially dog hair could
be human hair but that is reasonable
doubt if the prosecution can't explain
that away the defense can harp on that
and again we always say this you just
need one if one person can attach their
theory of this case within the jury to
say hey here's a lead they never chase
down Alec Murdock is as Blonde as they
come it could have been him that could
be something the defense could really
open up in this case and Terry people
are wrestling with this case people have
opinions about it one thing we never
talked about is why do you think this
trial is attracted such interest from so
many people you know what this is an
interesting case for a couple of reasons
first of all the Fall From Grace it is a
story that people are excited and
interested sadly enough to hear about
you know generations of solicitors in
his family it's the same as you know the
district attorney and the fact that he
himself is an attorney in the community
and now he's behind bars so I think
that's one reason the other issue here
is it is so convoluted the fact that he
is addicted to drugs the fact that so
many people have died I don't want to
say under his watch but around him
Gloria Satterfield his housekeeper this
young boy who was found on the street
hit by a car and he died you know
obviously Mallory Beach the young woman
who died in the boat accident when Paul
was driving and now of course the murder
of his wife and his son Paul so I
definitely think people are interested
in this story because it has so many
components and it is such a big huge
Fall From Grace Brian I'm going to throw
this back with you on this because let
me just ask you do you think it's the
mystery component too I mean the idea of
the unsolved mystery we saw it with
co-burger we saw it with Gabby Patito I
don't think there's a clear-cut answer
here whether or not he did it or not
absolutely Jesse in a lot of the cases
that we follow and the ones that we
really dig into it's not just the guilt
that people and we are trying to analyze
but whether or not the prosecutor is
going to improve their case whether or
not there is some piece of evidence that
could go either way when reasonable
Minds can disagree on a case that's what
I think becomes so fascinating
especially when you're talking about the
criminal justice system how they're
going to prove for example in this case
whether or not Alec Murdock was in the
area that the prosecution believes in to
be you're gonna have to go into the
science of cell phone pinging and
whether or not there's enough Towers
close by why is there no blood on his
clothes he says that he's there treating
them but we're watching him in there in
the front seat of the police car and he
seems to be as clean as the day that he
probably walked into that that that that
area and that scene and so those facts
those issues those legal arguments and
the fact that this person comes from a
dynasty as you said a dynasty of uh
prosecutors and Terry pointed out Fall
From Grace there's so many elements in
this case there's so many murders and
Mysteries that no one can keep their
eyes off of it unfortunately is very
unique for all the wrong reasons stay
with us for gavel to gavel coverage of
this very high profile trial you can
check out our links to videos live
streams from the courtroom all on
longcrime.com
[Music]
and welcome back everybody may recall
the ongoing case of Doomsday cult Mom
Lori vallo day Bell out in Idaho well in
a new twist her defense team is trying
to get the case thrown out altogether
saying time is up for the prosecution
Lori valadebell is being tried alongside
her husband Chad dabell for the deaths
of Lori's two children J.J valo and
Tyler Ryan the death of Chad's first
wife Tammy Davis was also included in
the charges in a new defense motion to
dismiss the case Lori's attorneys claim
that the state violated their clients
right to a speedy trial a speedy trial
should happen within six months of the
charges a new trial date is set for
April of this year but the charges were
filed in April of last year there have
been so many delays to this trial
including for Lori's own competency
hearings but her team says even then
she's been behind bars way too long in
total she'll have spent nearly 1200 days
in jail ruling from the judge is
currently pending so Brian the Idaho
statute for Speedy trials says that a
case needs to go to trial in six months
her defense team says it's going to be a
thousand days before she goes to trial
that just seems like simple math yeah
unfortunately Jesse the most difficult
thing for lawyers is just that simple
amount but the way I explain it to
people the right to a speedy trial is
not that six months exactly the same the
analogy I give is you've never seen an
NBA basketball game end in 48 minutes
even though each quarter is only 12
minutes because there's halftime on
timeouts there's commercial breaks
things like that and throughout the
pendency of a case there's also the
stopping and starting of that right to a
speedy trial clock uh emotion could stop
the clock the pendency evaluation could
stop the clock and so when you talk
about six months you have to look in
between the gaps in which that time is
running the other question here is Chad
day Bell waived his right to a speedy
trial Lori did not how does that work
out when one co-defendant waves but the
other does not and their cases are
joined together every state interprets
this right under this sixth amendment
differently it's just going to be a
matter of how this very complex math
plays out when you think about when the
clock starts and stops don't worry this
case isn't complicated enough just add
this on no no big deal so Terry you know
what I'm going to ask you
any possibility
this could actually happen any chance
her case is going to be dismissed
absolutely not listen these are
extremely serious charges the fact that
both of them have been accused of murder
of the children JJ and Tyler and there's
no question that they're not going to
get out and Lori asking I think this
motion is frankly ludicrous the fact
that because there's been a delay she's
caused most of those delays and she's
saying oh I think the case should be
dismissed because of the delays that's
not going to fly with the judge and true
judge Boyce has said he's a little bit
concerned about the fact that she's been
behind bars for so long but I don't
think he's going to look at that as an
opportunity to dismiss the case one of
the things Brian said that I think is
really true perhaps this case should not
have been joined in the first place Chad
is asking for different relief he's
saying let's postpone till further
notice basically and she is saying oh I
want a speedy trial that in and of
itself I think could give the judge some
opportunity to think about even now
separating these two cases because their
interests are not the same and in my
opinion they've never been the same so
we'll see what happens it's a textbook
example A lot of times people wonder why
do trials they don't happen until so
many years later kind of seeing it here
Brian Terry thanks so much everyone out
there thank you so much we'll see you
next time as we discuss Justice in
America
foreign